in the six weeks since the bank of
England last met the set interest rates
there have been two prime ministers two
chancellors and a crisis of confidence
in the UK economy the bank's response
the biggest single interest rate
increase is way back in 1989 a 0.75
percentage Point increase taking rates
to three percent their highest since the
2008 financial crisis and it says rates
will rise further but perhaps not as
high as the current Peak the market
expects of close to five percent it's
acted because inflation is running at
more than 10 it could Peak at 11 again
the highest it's way back in the 1980s
and a product of high energy prices
exacerbated by the war in Ukraine the
banks worry is that this imported
inflation could become embedded in the
UK economy as wages rise to keep up so
by increasing rates the bank is trying
to squeeze demand and bring inflation
down and what does it mean for mortgage
holders well today's increase alone will
have added 700 pounds a year to
repayments on a one hundred thousand
pound track a mortgage and fixed rates
have soared look at this the current
average rates for two and five year
fixed mortgage mortgages they're both
more than six percent a huge increase in
cost imposed in just the last few weeks
and the bank is clear responsibility for
a chunk of that extra cost lies with Liz
truss and quasi-quarting this chart
shows the yield on 10-year UK guilds
there are proxy a measure for government
borrowing the Blue Area shows the impact
of what the bank says are international
factors shared across the world the red
is what it calls the UK premium that's
an additional cost of more than two
percent since August imposed on
homeowners businesses and government
made worse by the mini budget in
September that's what happens next
that's the bleakest bit of the bank's
Outlook it's forecasting a recession
lasting up to two years this shows its
projections for GDP the size of the
economy and it's getting smaller the
pink line the higher line here is the
path of a recession if rates remained at
three percent we know they'll go higher
the darker line is if they increase in
line with Market expectations the
reality is it'll be somewhere in here in
between but it still means a recession
lasting deep into 2024 and only slow
recovery after that with unemployment
peaking at around six and a half percent
and at no point does the bank's forecast
say the economy will return to
pre-covered sizes the UK it seems will
pay a high price for the pandemic for
war in Europe and political turbulence
at home